in clever girl news I know that
reference submitted by Momo frumpy oh
what's up how's a 12 year old girl stops
the carjacker from abducting her and her
little sister what did she do
take jujitsu I'm going to show you guys
a video of her interview Michelle
telling you herself
alright what happened alright let's do
it that's crazy because I automatically
assume every timers have done that so I
was it was amazing I think that's pretty
good to think the good assumption has a
dysfunction did you say Kirito shouting
a carjacker in their tracks was the only
thing on this twelve-year-old girls mind
when a James City County man tried to
steal her mom's car with her little
sister inside everywhere she's bigger
than a reporter she's articulate
year-old sister Molly we're on their way
to Busch Gardens I got a dog named
Maddie Maddie's mom pulled over to help
but while she was on the phone with 911
the man who caused the accident Paul
Saltzman approached Jesus Wow police and
Maddy say the suspect came up to the
vehicle reached through the window
unlocked the car and climbed in somebody
rigged a lot wrong maddie was ready for
a fight and I put the car and drive
because that's a safety feature in the
van as I put it in Drive and held it
there and just started punching him and
every horrible little mr. Molly was able
to make it out of the vehicle
good girl that he was gonna not marry
mommy older sister gave Feldman a
beatdown
Wow because she has never done that dude
that go punch this Ohashi poker alarm
yeah no biggie is oh she's tall her dad
looks like a cop or something to have a
sunglass hand by the engine she's armed
are to know that that be sure no
roulette is very smart no no Maddy
suffered a fractured growth she's smart
bravery oh yeah it hurt but her message
to young girls is clear never ever give
up 12 year old Maddie wheeler taking
action and getting results
well her message to young girl is clear
there's never ever Google I'm knocking
microphone so shitty she needs to get
into MMA I want to watch her next fight
yeah how big do you think she is like
she's like five six or five eight I
don't know she look how so I wait I was
you were like 199 because she was bigger
than the reporter and her mom yeah she
looks like she's like my date or
something yeah yeah I don't have that
information she's quick thinking no
diamond driving I would never think
especially I'm in panic mode you have I
would not she's using her yep I'm
y'all's are stayed calm and thanks
you've got some [ __ ] arms yes I mean
some girls can bottle in there crazy and
it comes out in the right moment here
right no didn't you go to school with
the arm your arm in a sling invisible
rocks yes he does know so like I'm not
that centered in a panic situation isn't
no imagine you go to school your armor
sling as I hey what happened I'm is like
oh yeah I was kicking ass and yeah
carjacking was kicking so much ass that
broke my own arm because because she's
not like a dainty little girl I feel
like her hits made some impact hell yeah
broke her freaking hand punching that's
hardcore like most people are like not
trying to break their own hand hurting
someone that's murderous moves yeah I
think especially odd if a Jesus looking
do with a - yeah I'm [ __ ] scared how
do you think this guy is 65 yeah he
looks older than he is
yeah he falling upon 21 home do can I
just say if if referee Herb Dean I think
we all know about this okay if referee
Herb Dean was officiating this match and
this little girls wail on this news face
he would have called it way too early up
and I think that I think that's about
though I think what helps her too is the
fact that she's 12 she doesn't
understand like any repercussion that's
going to happen like she might break her
hand she doesn't understand that like
medical bills might sue she's just like
one with her heart yeah
I know all of us would be like what if
you strap with the eyes then or you know
you second-guess everything yeah like I
don't want to be in danger just let me
take the Karma to roll out like yeah it
was kind of strike first don't think the
strike first and murder the [ __ ]
Lucy I think you got out crazies
[ __ ] cuz I fan if they are
strapped how are they going to shoot you
they're dead
there's no like Mel Gibson and weak a
weapon do remember that scene where he's
like physics come on now I can't do it a
lot he like makes the guys with the gun
to his [ __ ] head he's like I want to
do it come on you like do it I can do it
it's like the guys like no hey man you
okay that's what I do I [ __ ] how
crazy that yeah yeah [ __ ] you you should
do it
so I can like let's see if there's
anything more in my stomach please the
guy say what the [ __ ] am i in there okay
I like that the little sister too smart
too because they're like do you picture
the [ __ ] off if you're trying to save it
you work so hard they're so [ __ ] dumb
that they don't even know what's going
on there just like frozen see up yeah
there's some car people kids love it
well even the mom said they went over
safety things before that's what you got
to do practice situations she's been
waiting for that moment I got a buddy
who'd be like what do you want you need
you met four you'll never use it it's
like tell that to this kid you always
use it yeah I think about that all the
time like what if an intruder came in
here right now what would I do like the
same thing I do scenarios with my
girlfriend I put up targets and then I
put two guns inside the car and I was
like I'm driving we just got home and
then but when do we ever have guns on
our laps
I don't know but I was like alright and
then there's people that came up to us
with guns what are we going to do I'm
gonna get up here and we just thought of
shooting the targets with the airsoft
guns and practice alright and you go
behind my back that was pretty funny
making everything and this is serious
it's like very important is like so
there's a guy in the house he's got a
gun right and it's like this
Oh your hand is a gator yeah am i happy
together damn I am I is he gone
you know yeah that works pretty good
that's pretty good drill so far I like
it works pretty good yes that's our
drill we practice drills while we're
walking dogs
so we just walk the dogs around the
corner not my eye so there's a shirtless
crackhead coming down the street and
he's like scratching everybody and we're
next right yeah you [ __ ] scratching
the [ __ ] out of everyone what are you
gonna do like just take the dogs run
behind me go call the police and I'll
run the other way we'll distract them
and see who he catches first I love it
we're gonna die cuz while we're walking
our dogs were like look at Brittany Bowl
like looking at a butthole like open it
: oh well your dogs are so big though
I'm pretty sure that's like crackhead
repellent I like that you're watching
your dog's [ __ ] and he's thinking of
how he can do a match [ __ ] intruder
gonna die I even did that one I would go
on walks in my neighborhood with my dog
by first of all in fij when I run a dog
known I don't anymore uh when I lived at
home when I was like a kid like it was
like 12 13 so like I have headphones in
but there's no music and then I had my
dog and he's like a big pit bull mix
like he's a black dog and like he's a
pit bull lab mix and guys would always
like always young guys like teenage guys
would be on the bike path where like I'm
walking my dog and they try to like toss
to me and like hit on me I was but I
don't know they could follow me home
they're bigger than me so baby like is
your dog friendly I'm like mmm
he bites only if I tell him to and I'd
be like so he's pretty nice but like
yeah like yeah exactly
and they'd be like oh okay well I won't
touch him Emma and I just be like so on
edge about the dog the whole time then
they probably wouldn't follow I was so
stupid I think my mom try to have that
communication with me as a kid and I
[ __ ] it up and I got yelled at so we
one of our pipes broke in the sink I
think this is violence eight or nine and
my parents are divorced at this time so
my mom is like a single lady with me in
the house and I was just playing around
with my daughter in the backyard
we had a plumber come over and I think
he was starting to like overstay his
welcome a little bit
like like inviting himself to lunch or
this is going to take longer than it's
supposed to be whatever and then on my
mom's like oh I'm just gonna bring out
the dog from the side alley because
that's where he was playing I'm okay
cool so I brought him out my mom watch
Department of me Michael which is the
name of my dog open the door
Michael comes out and I'm like that's my
god Michael and then he was like wait he
is he friendly
am i gay and I immediately I see my mom
giving with this [ __ ] death stare and
I'm like I don't even know what's going
on and then later on just telling me
yeah I was so dumb I didn't catch the
signs yeah I found out later that my mom
was trying to like scare him and let him
know that he can't have his way in this
house and be careful by just kind of
[ __ ] on it laughter I don't remember
that's the part you know like you only
remember like different pieces of your
childhood I just I probably ought my ass
be and I forgot so I don't know did you
beat the memory out uh-huh
no this sounds like that me and
everything with chills oh you but yeah
he ended up leaving but not after the
dog thing urger not because of the dog I
mean no to the handler petting and I
remember he went oh look fine because
your mom letter let him have his way
with her and then we messed it up oh my
god that's today I didn't hear about
this little brother do you want that
Mike oh yeah one time to what nuns can
honor Jesus I was like oh my god he said
some - yeah that's why it's good to have
these drills oh and then especially if
kids are so dumb
yeah it was I don't know what was going
on so true I thought my mom wanted me to
bring the dog out so that the plumber
could be friends with the dog yeah so
yeah I think I'm prepping him because
he's gonna be flying alone from here to
Dallas so I've been prepping him telling
him like don't talk to strangers
exchanges are trying to like talk to you
to tell them I can't talk to strangers
and it's okay to be rude as a kid
because they'll be forgiven I'm just
trying to give them like trying to press
him like changes how to watch out for me
my mom was a lady watching Oprah and
like Oprah's like it can happen to you
and then you see like footage of a car
filling up with water and then like
click someone struggling to get out of
the car and it's like so you got to buy
this book an icepick thing that this
lady like invented she's a mom or what
weren't you sore hits it opens up or
whatever and so mom looks it I'm
ordering it right now I don't even get
I'm getting it right now Stephen and I'm
like and I'm like mom and I live next to
a body of water where we've we're in
Virginia there's Virginia Beach and I'm
like it's like [ __ ] waves like you
don't ride into the beat right yeah you
two go off-roading on the beach looking
weird
my mom just gets it like that's how they
got like suburban house mom like that
said we had a safe word because we watch
we're watching Fox News one day about a
kid that got kidnapped in like how you
should have a safe words and stuff like
that and so our safe word was Fox who we
saw it on Fox News I never got to you
have you got in trouble all right yeah
shouldn't trouble how's it going guys
don't forget to like the video because
if you don't I will break your [ __ ]
legs thank you so much for the last
video don't forget to click right here
or I'll break your [ __ ] arms click
right here guys